uh robert's fans they seem more nuts
no offense because they're quite some of
them are quite out there
yeah i mean i think they just like
[Music]
i uh i think you get it i have a much
more simplistic reaction with
fans that i think like it's like you
know
i i i it's like screaming and so it's
kind of
and so it limits it i think you get
because like you know when we've been
doing these
with these premiers and stuff there's
like an overwhelming amount of energy
and i think it's because if this
everyone's just trying to do the same
thing they've only got one thing to say
like which is just screaming and you can
just like really focus all your energy
together and it's like it's really
powerful
it's like uh excalibur or the captain
planet or something
i was going up to a screaming girl and
freaking her out by going hi what's your
name
i've always wanted to do a sketch for
some comedy show where i'd
go down you know you better premiere
whatever would be screaming and uh
go back to the sort of dungeon place and
then you have all these fans locked up
in this like german techno meeting just
scream at them
how many go up and like zac efron's at
the top of the stairs going in next or
something
they didn't let me do it and uh margaret
robert you're in town
whooping it up you've got the baptist
this weekend and you the birds of prey
premiere on wednesday and
now comic book heroes and action films
we kind of assume
they appeal to kind of nerdy boys
essentially yeah
and you kind of forget there are lots of
nerdy women out there
who like these films yeah i think
everyone's got their inner nerd
yeah well you are a proper nerd aren't
you i mean when it comes to harry potter
i'm a massive massive nerd
well we know that because you posted
this book is this your 12th or
you're about 12 or 13 here this is
margot robbie look how uncool
do you know what's particularly pathetic
about this picture a couple things
number really i'll let you point them
out number one
it's my birthday that's how i chose to
spend my birthday
what was in the cup uh number two i'm
drinking tea
uh number three i'm wearing glasses even
though i don't need glasses i lied to
the optometrist because i wanted to have
glasses like that
now daniel i think you were where are
you at harry potter fan and i love harry
potter i just to get round to reading
the last one okay so
i just i was i have stuff to do mom
i was getting i don't know what happened
i was just like i'll do it later and
then
are you kidding me so you've read one to
six and you haven't read the seven
yeah i don't know are you actually
kidding
couldn't bear for twins i'm like not
going to be able to sleep tonight
worrying about you life is a game you
mean
i just like you it's just you keep it on
the edge i mean
this is insane to me do you know another
fun
fact my husband it's your thing this is
fascinating
i can go on about this forever i'm so
sorry i brought this up
i have no one else to blame
um my husband is in the harry potter
movies
i know i was like had you told me sooner
we would have been married very quickly
but he was
um an extra he was like when he was a
little kid he's like one of the
slaughtering
extras you know when draco like pushes
some kids out of the way to see buckbeak
in the third book
yeah he pushes my husband out of the way
[Applause]
yeah i know but then it's interesting
one of the scariest things you did
and it's something that i just assumed
you had done before
with stand-up comedy stand-up comedy
i had never done that was the first time
that i ever did stand up
and you know i just watched your last
netflix special
which is so good thank you great yeah
like it is
to me stand up is the hardest thing to
do in entertainment it's different than
music
when you have a beat and you have rhythm
and you go and it's like you got backup
dancers and you got dj jazzy jeff
you know it's like when you have all of
that it's like you're
you're surrounded and protected you know
even with a hit
record when you have a hit record you
know the audience is going to respond
you know it's going to go well stand up
that's stuff
out there just you and a microphone did
you get the bug did you kind of think
i'm going to do this again
no i i went out there and i really i
really enjoyed it
but when i was preparing for the
stand-up i was thinking to myself i
would much rather bungee jump out of a
helicopter again
it's terrifying to me but i can see you
doing it though i can actually see you
doing it and having success doing it
because
the beauty of it is talking yeah you got
stories you got an amazing point of view
so i think once you grasp
that side of it i'm just sharing my
point of view yeah people are going to
understand and gravitate towards the
pictures that i'm painting because
they're true they're believable it's
authentic
you had them so i couldn't because you
could you did you didn't tell to
yourself like
the story about your dad is true my dad
yeah so the one where he phones you oh
yeah
it was um it was uh independence day and
uh
the movie had just come out it was uh
you know that my first big
hit movie so it's like it was you know
like
3 a.m in in la and he was on the east
coast and he had just
seen the numbers so the phone rings and
at 3am calls i grab
it and i'm like hello and he's like hey
you see them numbers and i was like
dad it's three o'clock i i didn't see
you remember when i told you there ain't
no such thing as luck
just what you make remember i told you
that okay
dad yeah i remember that remember when i
told you
ain't no such thing as luck luck is when
opportunity
meets preparation remember i told you
that
yeah dad dad i remember he said man
that's [__] you're the luckiest joke
i've ever made in my
life
[Applause]
you know cara levine you you know you
are professional martial that you say my
whole name
is something is it the in-flight
magazine of derelingus okay
because i think it is isn't it
means friends so that could be a thing
you know i think it is
that's probably why i'm not saying cara
yeah okay rolls up the potato
so carla levine uh even she on a red
carpet you can get distracted we've got
a picture of you
with your co-star distracting things on
the red carpet yes well this is you with
brianna
you look sad
guys you wouldn't
it's just like hello i mean i remember
because
i i've known her for a very long time
and i just remember seeing because every
time
i mean especially in that show she
obviously has magnificent
lungs yes obviously nobody she i'm you
know i just went up to i was like you
look amazing then
every time she was like you've got to be
on boob watch and so i just because you
know it's definitely something you have
to be careful
but i was i was being a good friend it
doesn't look like it but it was it was
cold
no you do look very relaxed but uh but
apparently you were wearing were you
wearing a thermally thing
yeah you know because i was out there
for a while so they have like a very
thin
wetsuit that you put on so you don't
freeze to death
okay well that's good yes yeah and uh
it's funny because i actually went out i
was
they had a nice crane shot they went out
there in front of me and
i was walking out but you know if you
have a wetsuit on the air gets kind of
trapped in there
and he's walking out and the bubbles
start coming up and right when it gets
to the level where it's at
all these bubbles come out like
you fart and the camera's right there
and i'm like
i start giggling because of the because
of the bubbles because i can feel them
go up too
and then i open it up to let the air out
and then all the cold went in
so my interaction was all like
many emotions went through me and not to
dwell on this picture too much
but um
some of these tattoos are real so yeah
it was uh
zach had the idea he wanted to put
my tattoos on my family like my family
crest
and uh he wanted to you know put it
everywhere okay so these are just what
they yeah well they're uh they're like
stickers it takes quite a bit i mean
there's about an
hour and a half make up in the morning
just to put them all on but there's like
odd pieces that they have to put on and
it takes about
it takes a long time to get them off it
was the same in sense and sensibility
and so in all those action sequences are
you one of those guys do you do all your
own stunts or
i'd like to yeah i like to do a good
amount of suns because stunts are fun
and you know they're cool but
more so it's not really a ego thing it's
more so
the audience knows i would rather tie
myself into all the action
uh so they're able to see yes but no i'm
just thinking in a stunt scene yeah the
sun man is having a fight with you
if you hit him you could kill him
because some members like this isn't
fair and
if i miss then the wind behind the punch
will give an ammonia you'll die
they're good fight and talk fighting
talk that's a good line right yeah yeah
yeah like in a bar in a pond um
uh there was one when i first started
for example i did the scorpion king
and uh it was my very first movie and i
had this big action sequence and
um i wound up hitting a stuntman
and kind of clocking him super hard he
was a little older
he went down and i felt so bad
that was because he did
thank god but when you catch somebody
you know like with a point it just it
doesn't feel good so i i
i bought him a rolex watch and he was
but that's how bad i felt i felt super
bad because
i mean these guys are the backbone of
our business uh so i did buy him a rolex
watch but once that story gets out
then stunt people just aren't throwing
themselves
you're right by the way that's exactly
what happened so this story starts
getting out and there's a couple you
know you're getting these action
sequences and maybe guys will lean
ahead because you know i mean if we got
into a fight would would
would that be worth it too no no no
no
so if you can't do it how do they get
because
you are so physically kind of unique
looking how do they get
other people wow yeah yeah she's going
yeah yeah
thank you mom now she's crying
how do they get like a stunt guy to look
like you i've got a great stunt double
who's actually my cousin and we look
like twins
uh you do look like twins like that's
yeah yeah
doesn't he kind of think why don't i be
a movie star though
by the way that i got the smile there
that's a smile like yeah
i'm the star of the movie and then he's
just like yeah i'm getting my ass kicked
the voice christian bale now he did it
himself
yes he did but this time it's a
different version well like i said
christian's a
great actor for me i had required
electronic manipulation of the voice to
do it i
we we kind of thought we posited that he
was a he was a famous billionaire
and so that people would recognize his
real voice and it would give away his
identity
so that in within the cowl is an
electronic device that changes batman's
voice
for him so that he's not recognized so
that it digitally manipulates the voice
so i performed the voice
and then zach was able to change it with
a computer later on
so i just played the part and then you
know when i watch the movie it's the
voice is different it's electrical
because we've got a mic
and i think this is set up oh it is
isn't that amazing
do you do because do you do the thing
when you know that it's going to do it
but you still do it too like you you do
it on top of the thing you do it can you
give us some
some like lines sure sure
do
[Music]
[Applause]
that was really good have a go henry why
not
what would superman say i'm batman
and i'm secretly in love with superman
okay let's go start let's stop let's
stop now
there's been a lot i think more than
normal
this time round a lot's been made about
uh
superman's disguise as clark kent
yeah and
how really light it is it's it's a very
light
disguise seemingly so really like i've
got the glasses
so if you just pop them on so we can see
the difference that the glasses make
just pass them down here we go
prepare to be amazed
oh where's henry gone
that's really creepy crazy
it's even creepy when you say it in that
voice
because it is one of those things it's
amazing that either they haven't
come up with some sort of backstory or
like you kind of think in 2016 they
wouldn't just put you in some glasses
and say
and no one will know who you are
but actually didn't you do an experiment
i did indeed
yeah to be a counterpoint to what you're
talking about yeah to just
prove you wrong in fact um we were a
friend of mine and i were discussing the
idea of these glasses not being good
enough to skies
and uh we decided to go to times square
to test the theory i wore a superman
t-shirt and
no glasses and stood underneath the
giant wrap around
batman's superman posters in times
square we've got a picture oh there's
there you are
and took a bunch of other photos and
some video as well
and uh got stopped twice
once by someone exiting the subway
asking for directions at central station
and the other time was in a coffee shop
where someone said could you please stop
taking photos
that was it that is bizarre yeah yeah
it's it's apparently very easy to do can
you say you just really better
be boring you look really comfortable in
those classes
oh for once